[Musica]
questo nuova guida e oggi volevo
praticamente descrivervi la mia prima
volta in sella e tutto ciò appunto da un
albero
adesso potete benissimo vedere questa
immagine rappresenta praticamente il
mondiale 2018 di moto gp
io sono esattamente quello là il pilota
o li vedete il primo aereo con gli sono
scarse c'è una frecciatina praticamente
sono quel piccolo puntino ii e questo
immagini vi posso dire che c'era
qualcosa di fantastico della mia vita è
adesso scoprite perché tutto tutto
praticamente inizio quando questo che va
da un'immagine mi ha praticamente sono a
4 metri di altezza circa 80 90 km orari
pensate se questo qui i ragazzi sono
proprio io adesso vi voglio spiegare più
o meno come sono arrivato qua allora
tutto iniziò quando nell'isola 12 anni
ok i mesi quanti mesi il mio bel casco
tutto bello guardato contento e andai
verso questa bellissima campagna una
strada lunga lunghissima c'era un albero
ok
sì sì c'era poco un albero praticamente
immaginate che questo qui sono io
dieci anni io a 10 anni bellissimo
contento prima marcia
e praticamente la sera o ri disegnato
questo avete presente come nei cartoni
animati praticamente c'è un albero in
mezzo a chilometri quadrati quell'albero
li fa da calamita bam strascicato
fortunatamente io sono rimasto illeso se
no questo non sarebbe a parlare però la
moto effettivamente era in mille pezzi
ragionando il secondo c'è stato un
piccolo imprevisto cioè l'albero in quel
caso li rappresentava il mio limite
ok perché non doveva fermare un albero
voi pensate con un ragazzo dieci anni si
schianto a controllare bruno un po di
paura potrebbe potrebbe avere ok
e invece ho detto no voglio andare
avanti
non volevo fare altro poteva darmi
benissimo la dama perché morelli alberi
non c'erano ho detto voglio superare il
mio limite
c'è un albero non può vincere su di me
la difficoltà in quel caso di è servita
da punto iniziale da poter crescere e lì
mi sono reso conto di tantissime cose ok
volevo portarvi l'esempio di una
grandissima persona
si chiama julio velasco è un allenatore
della nazionale di pallavolo
praticamente lui tutto ravanelli aziende
e parla con i manager e con tutte quelle
persone che lavorano all'interno di
un'azienda per spronarli nel loro lavoro
quindi cercare di migliorare l'ambiente
lavorativo in cui si lavora facendo un
team un gruppo poi pensate che puyol e
lasko aveva la sua squadra di pallavolo
i giocatori professionisti ai giocatori
professionisti li prendeva andavo in
spiaggia perdeva i giocatori della
nazionale ok ai giocatori cosa facevano
si crearono si creavano delle alibi le
abili gli alibi cosa sono delle scuse
ora dicevo non siamo abituati a giocarsi
un qualche nei salti anno scacciamo loro
non riuscivano a saltare perché erano
sulla sabbia non erano su qualche e
quindi julio velasco doveva sfornati
perché diceva scusate dovete mutare le
vostre competenze mutare le vostre
abilità sul campo perché fai così e la
sabbia diventa qualche ok diciamo che ha
fatto io ho fatto più o meno la stessa
cosa perché fortunatamente quando era
andato addosso all'albero la moto non
era mia ok no non era nella moto e
diciamo che ho creato insieme alla moto
insieme al mio amico ho fatto gruppo
quindi la forza di aver creato quel
gruppo li ha creato in me interesse ok
in quel caso lì mi sono appassionato
museo di più al mondo del motociclismo
perché mi sono messo lì nella posto il
freno non c'è posso quello particamente
c'era la moto che era disfatta in mezzo
ai garage e mia madre che mi chiamava mi
urlava dietro cosa non dovesse
rispondere
in quel caso lì la l'interesse a crearne
una forte conoscenza nell'ambito del
motociclismo questo infatti è stato uno
dei miei primi traguardi che è stata lei
a prima moto ok è una moto da enduro che
quindi voi come state come una moto
enduro to prendeva in un bosco pensate
prima vedevo un albero
adesso vado nel bosco e trovo centinaia
gli altri capoluoghi in cui io non
dovevo stare praticamente infatti più
alberi c'erano però aumentando le mie
capacità che cosa ho notato cavoli più
opportunità di poter divertirmi però
maggiori sono state le responsabilità
che è perché capisce che io rompo la mia
moto non avere la mia madre chissà
più responsabilità perché potevo farmi
male perché ovviamente quando andavo nel
bosco andavo in montagna io potevo farmi
noi locali e appuntamento i miei lavori
non ospedali ogni volta mi chiedevano a
casa così col braccio che casini
interpellato
vabbè aneddoti che sono successi però
comunque più entusiasmo più abilità che
o son riuscito a cogliere dell'enduro ok
questo è stato un primo traguardo che è
quindi io mi sotto da provare
nel mondo del motocross questo chi sono
io praticamente col gas spalancato a due
mani che praticamente voi pensate che
nel motocross gli alberi non ci sono più
ok non ci sono però ci sono piloti su
una moto piloti moto c'è praticamente
quegli alberi diventano persone
voi pensate che quando partiamo siamo
sulla griglia
siamo sul nostro cancelletto e siamo
fino a 40 piloti su 40 moto quindi sono
circa 80 ostacoli sono degli ostacoli
che corrono cadono saltano sassi voi
pensate che confusione ci potrebbe
essere alla partenza sulla prima curva
ovviamente maggiori sono le difficoltà
il desidero di sfida è una cosa molto
importante perché normalmente to
finalmente in cui tu sei in gara
praticamente tutti hanno lo stesso
pensiero fisso di arrivare la primo
facciamo 80 80 in prima posizione no
maggio è quindi sono le responsabilità
perché ovviamente andranno su un albero
ok file via la corteccia
se vedo su una persona penso che sia un
po più diverso la cosa perché faccio
tutto questo
voi dovete capire che io sono un malato
di adrenalina in quella lì la formula
chimica lo sapevo ma qual è la formula
chimica dell'adrenalina ve lo giuro
niente dopodiché iniziai ad entrare nel
mondo delle competizioni
diciamo che quando si entra in gara odio
si punta primi la sia molta paura di
perdere perché ovviamente quando se in
gara hai di fronte un sacco di avversari
sempre per farvi capire che tutte allo
stesso pensiero di andare latini e lo
strato sic logico è molto alto per il
fatto che ha il pubblico e ti fischia il
team che ti dice tu devi puntare alla
vittoria ok
ovviamente volevo fare una piccola cosa
quando si entra il mondo delle gare a un
vero pilota pensa a vincere ma non
pensando di essere il vincente durante
la gara perché perfetto il vincente
colui che prende arriva prima il vero
vincente quindi diciamo una sorta di il
leader è colui che è arrivato primo
perfetto ma ha portato dietro di se un
gruppo di persone
ok quindi il campione vince però pensato
se ok invece chi è leader ha lavorato
per sé ma soprattutto per gli altri
ministri non è che io corro per arrivare
ultimo magari preferisco arrivare una
posizione sotto ma verrà illustrato il
mio compagno di scuola
quindi diciamo volevo mettere una
conclusione
per me è appunto lo sport e la vita al
viaggio di parallelo che cosa hanno
insegnato allo sport che di fronte alle
difficoltà non bisogna mai fermarsi zero
alibi 0
cosa che diceva quello che dice voglio
velasco ok vince che non smette mai di
mettersi in gioco
questa frase che cosa vuol dire vuol
dire che di fronte alla difficoltà
noi dobbiamo provarci sbagliamo perfetto
ma noi dobbiamo pensare che quali è la
nostra occasione di crescita e niente vi
ringrazio tutti di averne ascoltato e
dimenticavo una piccola cosa finisce
questa giornata a voi uscite beccato un
albero abbracciate lo ce la faccio li
fate una bella pacca sul ramo gli dite
grazie perché per me un semplice albero
e stato un ottimo allenatore
[Applauso]
[Musica]